marketing for the now the marketing for
the now marketing for the now marketing
for the now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary
what do you think
gary gary gary
hello how are you i'm from the kitchen
and guess where i am gary
in the
living i'm in the bathroom
we are on a company off site so we're
all in the same house go ahead andrea
take it over oh my gosh all right this
is gonna be awesome we've got one a
one-hour show we've got six incredible
guests today and we have one question
how do you figure out what makes
customers tick we're going to be kicking
off with peter murray
peter is the ceo and board member of the
professional fighters league the pfl is
the first organization ever to present
mma in a true sport format with
individual fighters competing in a
regular season playoffs and world
championship it's distributed on espn
and additionally 160 plus countries
worldwide and later on tonight the pfl
has its second playoffs card
and we can't wait for peter to tell us
more all about that welcome peter
hey thank you andrea great to be with
you gary
peter it's great to see you my friend uh
first two seconds for everybody on the
pfl for maybe the small percentage that
doesn't know what it is
yeah real quickly i mean we're uh the
number two mma organization in the world
uh what makes us different is our format
that's the key differentiator our
fighters fighting a regular season to
play off an achievement format no
different than the
npl the nba and it's really propelling
our growth
in particular on top of that technology
the use of that and
storytelling
i love it so peter let's just get right
into it
how does the organization uh and and you
for that matter as the chief executive
officer how do you guys figure out what
makes a customer tick like how do you
get to that how do you figure that out
yeah i mean i i love the question and
you know we launched as a challenger
brand and a disruptor you know in sports
and mma and our business thesis there's
there's more room for more than one
leader in the sport so yeah the the
first thing you have to do is
who's the consumer
is you know what's the opportunity and
we quickly surmised that mma as the
fastest growing sport
uh today in the world 550 million fans
youngest fan base
and they're underserved so again data
and insights looking at content around
the world engagement around the world
fans around the world so we start with
that premise and the business premise
and then what makes them tick for me
four things well the first thing you
gotta do is talk to them
but most importantly
listen
and and i don't need to tell you this or
you know many of the viewers and
engagers today
with digital and social channels and
conversation it's a lot you know a lot
of positive a lot of negative but how
you breaking down that sentiment uh so
you know first and foremost we can talk
about but number one
talk to the customer i'm gonna go
somewhere interesting with you because i
think you as a ceo you're gonna be able
to give us a really good insight to this
for the people that are a little bit
further along in their careers maybe
destined to be a ceo in a big
organization soon
why do ceos
not do what they heard from the customer
from a business standpoint give me some
cliche reasons where
financially a partner
uh i'll give you example why i don't
peter because i have an executive that
wants to do something different than me
i and i'm i'm really good at listening
even though i'm always yapping
but it's important to me for my employee
to feel like i'm supporting her or him
even though i know they're going to lose
flat out and
now here's why it's fun nine out of ten
eight out of 10 times i'm right and it
becomes a learning experience
one out of two times i eat humble pie
and it's delicious to me that curiosity
humility is actually what allows me to
have the audacity to have bravado and
confidence
so
that would be an example i would say how
about from your standpoint you know what
the customer wants from your point of
view you're confident in your pattern
recognition or it's just your subjective
opinion
or there's some other force because a
lot of people are watching right now
don't get to the levels of decision
making that you and i have and they're
baffled when like how did coca-cola how
did the nfl how did tootsie rolls how
did puma not get it sometimes there's
even though they know what the answer is
they can't do it give us some reasons to
why even though you figured out what
makes the customer tick what's stopping
you yeah i mean i think hey you touched
on it's like one constrains two forces
and how you can find those constraints
sometimes operationally you may not be
able to get there you may want to listen
to that consumer but there's still a
business in in the path a company is
going on and uh you don't want to give
up on that um so you know there's
there's a lot of different constraints
in the marketplace and then other forces
and a lot of times those forces are
internal whether it be in the boardroom
whether it be investors whether it be
other key stakeholders who you're in
your career i'm starting to interrupt in
your career because these are short and
i'm actually genuinely curious
tell me a story doesn't have to be in
this role somewhere else where
you were devastated that it wasn't going
to get done because maybe you were a
young buck and the boss didn't do
something or the board stopped you
just give us an anecdotal story be as
specific as you can maybe you have to
hold off some information uh and
where it really went the other way or
maybe back to the humility maybe where
it worked
yeah no i i think something that comes
to mind is
you know while at under armour and and
you know fast growing company you know
domestically globally you know sort of
land driven product driven and in
particular on the product side
at times it takes time to realize the
vision
of a product and a value proposition you
know you want to go there you know the
consumer's begging for it you're solving
for something and it takes time to put
all those pieces together and then you
weigh okay is the juice worth the
squeeze
and and so yeah you know that that's
something that comes to mind you know
over over my time in under armour but
i'll tell you in the experience at the
pfl since since launching the pfl four
years ago now being the number two in
the world and again we're not satisfied
that we're poised to be a co-leader and
that's really what gets us up in the
morning in terms of building a
world-class global sports property in
mma and you go back to the customer we
talk to the customer you know people
within the mma world there's been no
innovation in mma
in two plus decades and so we came in a
lot of people said we talked by the way
we talked to consumers some consumers
said that format won't work this is it's
not well you're a football guy you guys
are stick and ball you don't know what
you're talking about boxing doesn't work
that way well boxy broke it you know
they're trying to fix it
and in mma but what we said but we heard
from other fans another group of fans
who were positive on it
and we took that negative but you know
what i i bring it back to some pot
sometimes people don't know what they
don't know
so you have to have conviction you got
to believe in the vision you know once
you you know you pick the lane you do
your best to get that marketplace data
all the stakeholders starting with the
consumer and they got away at all but
you go and i'm happy to say
we brought those people on board those
naysayers on board because it and then
for us
all starts with the product build a
great product you know
in the last minute and by the way vk i
see you say gary he started interrupting
the other guy i have no interest in
interrupting pete i've got 10 minutes
and i want to get amazing stuff out of
him and 10 minutes is a tough format so
i apologize pete
just for fun closing par because we got
one minute what's the first fight
that you got excited about as a kid
which i'm going to assume is either
boxing
or maybe even wrestling wwf uh as a just
a fun thing to get an insight to who is
peter murray what was the first fight
that caught your attention as a child
yeah you know i'm the youngest of five
you know older brothers and you know
muhammad ali growing up he was an icon
so you know every ali fight you know i
was sort of hooked and and how old were
you when ali fought homes because that
was probably the one you were old enough
right i was in grade school you know and
are you devastated because absolutely
you know what he stood for
you know not only his his you know he's
a champion but
but you know
his snatcher and socially you know he
was captivating so you know that that
really hooked me
peter thank you my friend have a great
day thank you gary take care see you
next we welcome morgan de bonne founder
and ceo of blavity inc the leading
digital company for black culture and
millennials blabbity reaches over 100
million readers per month through a
portfolio of media properties including
blavity news afrotech travel noir and
more morgan has been a renegade and a
serial entrepreneur starting when she
was a child
welcome morgan
thanks for having me
hi morgan how are you
you're doing well hey
uh let's just get right into the child
part first just because you know that
makes us you know brother and sister
right off the bat what was your what was
your childhood hustle because that's
where i always get the most smiley
look i was hustling the stock market
when i was about 14.
um and uh 13 14 is when i first started
like investing and then i also in middle
school
they banned uh candy and vending
machines it was like when everyone was
trying to be healthy
so i went to costco or sam's club with
my mom bought a bunch of candy and
started selling it you know and you know
ultimately i got in trouble but uh yeah
i was like the demand is not going
anywhere i once said to somebody when i
started becoming an investor i'm like i
have no interest in seeing any startup
from anybody who has not been in trouble
in middle school slinging something
that's right illegal as [ __ ] like weed
or lollipops it's all the same game
because that means it's in your blood
right like most kids aren't like you and
i go into the store thinking oh here's a
flip
right margins
margins
by the way the candy margin game in
school is still one of the greatest
margins that has ever lived absolutely
you go to sam's club it's like what 15
bucks and you get an entire case what
buckets
yeah
um morgan let's go into the question and
we'll we'll bounce around a little bit
like you know you've had this incredible
success of such a young woman and and a
powerhouse so early in your career
oh that can only happen only
when you actually know what makes the
customer tick
you know uh i i would say the candy
hustle was easy kids wanted candy as
you've matured into who you are today
you know how do you figure out
what makes a customer tick how do you do
it yeah to me it's about emotion right
like what is that uh motion that you can
bring to the customer so for blavity
there was a feeling of loneliness that
was the feeling that i had when i was
kind of in the tech world and working my
full-time job in tech and was like
i love it here but this is super lonely
like what am i supposed to do in my free
time what am i supposed to read how am i
connecting with people so actually
figuring out what emotional problem you
saw for somebody um makes it really
really sticky because then they feel
something and they remember it you know
it's not just a passing piece of content
or a passing interaction it's something
that actually sticks with them
are you good at
you if you were self-assessing and i
know you're young so like that keeps
evolving but at this exact moment do you
think you're good at scratching your own
itch
as a consumer
figure outer or do you think you are
good at research like black and white
data
do you think do you think that you've
got the ear you know for me i'm like oh
i'm a music ar i just do it for life
right i just i can't explain it i just
know nft i just know this i just know
that it's just in me culturally because
i think my empathy for humanity makes it
come logical to me which is like why i
play in so many pockets what do you
think your strength is of those three a
mix of the three how do you break that
down
you know i think when i first started i
was solving for my friends myself and
the problems that i had and so it was
definitely
yeah it was a scratcher but to get to
scale you can't just scratch yourself
right like i
am not a travelista but i know that
travel noir you know is something that
emotionally travel aspiration getting
that that vacation or just moving out of
your getting out of your city uh is
something that everybody wants to do and
that there was nobody doing that for
black people so that was also to some
extent intuition to what other people
may need and then listening just like
straight up looking at what's trending
in the mainstream white millennial media
spaces and then testing it with an
audience that's underserved it's really
it sounds
simple no no
like you're talking to somebody who
literally thinks
the only thing that matters is
simplicity which is why it's impossibly
hard because everybody who's listening
right now including us we're taught
by society and school
to complicate it
and very few of us
were able to luckily go into a cocoon of
our own dna or have parenting or have
some other force of the outside
that was allowing us to not conform to
complexity that's right
that's exactly right you said something
that i really liked and i want to double
click into because my obsession with the
show is to put people on that i want
people to know
and for everybody who's watching right
now to get something truly something
that they can build on i like what you
just said and i want to play with it a
little bit because i do it in a not in
the exact way you to
the audience that you do it but i do it
overall
you're watching what's happening in
mainstream white america
and you test it
do you test it in the pure form that
it's playing out over there or do you
test it with some contextual twist that
you're using for understanding the
nuance the slang the perspective that it
might garner or do you do both
that's right so i'll take afrotech as an
example it's a big tech conference you
know it's the number one black tech
conference and we just came in and
crushed the entire competition of black
tech conferences at that time what i did
was i went to google i o i went to f8
you know i went to the big
regular mainstream tech conferences and
i said oh wait a minute you guys have
huge beautiful booths you guys have
champagne you guys have incredible
spaces with great visuals you know we're
not at a hotel by the airport we're in
the main center and i just duplicated
that but for us but instead of having
like boring speakers i had rappers i had
producers i had you know the who's who
of the black innovation economy which
doesn't always look the same i did also
have your design folks your engineers
but it definitely was a black version of
the pattern that was uh best in class
what um what do you think is the
sneakiest data source whether black or
white meaning like data or quant or qual
um
what is the sneakiest quant or qual data
source right now you think in society
where are some where are some of the
ways to figure out the tick that maybe
people are underestimating or just
completely not looking at or just to
have fun here what's the most overrated
what do you think you know i think you
know
i could see you're ready to go so i'm
going to let you yeah i'm like i got a
lot of different things that i sneak
that people like what really yeah so i
always look at our competitors websites
and we figure out what their top
articles are for the month and for the
week and that just gives us insights
into topics that are trending that maybe
our audiences have never been exposed to
from us but we know they want to read or
we know that they're interested in um
instead of trying to guess it's like
well you know if michael b jordan is
trending then like we should maybe write
more about michael jordan
by the way on the record michael b
jordan should always be trending
he basically is trying to scream that's
why 2021 statement michael b jordan
should always be trembling he pretty
much is at 100 i agree with that yeah
yeah look at your direct competitors
what's working for them and figure out
if you need to test that um and then the
other thing is
yeah and then the other thing i was
going to say is look at where your
audience is and where they're playing
next so when clubhouse was coming out
you know i'm friends with andres and
horowitz guys so i was like early on
clubhouse and then i was like oh this
got black really fast okay yeah what's
happening here
and do we have this this sub demographic
of the black community if not that's
great now i get to learn more about what
they're interested in and then we can
apply that to our channels right so
uh it's just always studying your
audience club clubhouse was such a gift
and twitter spaces and facebook right
now you like you could be passively
listening
in the backdrop
to the current conversation of normal
human beings that's right it was like
the
most i mean it was my biggest problem
was i needed to create a fake account
right because everybody tried every
single time
i'm in the bathtub right now guys i
cannot talk
a hundred percent i i miss i miss the
days when nobody gave a [ __ ] about me or
who because that was that was that good
listening you know now it's like a
little bit harder final thoughts on
customer tick one more word of wisdom in
the last minute and thank you for being
on
yeah um you know i think the last thing
is i read a lot of emails from other
industries so i think that's just
getting outside of your own self um has
been really helpful to just like what's
going on in the like climate change
industry what's going on in fintech and
uh one of the things that i've learned
really early is that black people we're
early adopters so even in fintech it's
like cool
coinbase and all these other companies
that uh we're using them more than
average or like cash app right so
learning about what your customers are
using from a technology point of view
and even in just different industries
has helped us stay ahead of the curve
when it comes to content creation and
topics of conversation
it's been a real pleasure
thanks for having me have a great day
next up we've got bobby brown and for
the two people that don't know bobby as
a professional makeup artist she created
10 simple lipsticks and launched her
billion dollar brand bobby brown
cosmetics
she left her names day company in 2016
to return to her roots as an
entrepreneur launching a line of
wellness and beauty ingestibles an
editorial platform and a boutique hotel
welcome bobby
uh thank you so much and you get it did
you get in the makeup company which is
kind of the biggest thing i've done
my reason for getting up in the morning
besides being able to see my friend gary
if this is the only way i could
socialize with you hey gare how are you
bobby i've literally decided that i
basically do all these different content
series so you could be a guest on what i
do so it's so nice to see you having a
good summer um great summer i'm ready
for fall i'm not gonna lie but i'm ready
yeah i've had a great summer
as somebody who i think just has an
innate superpower of understanding the
audiences she's been trying to go after
what do you think it is about
your dna or the process you have there's
a lot of people listening right now who
are in different parts of their journey
starting out or
cmos of the biggest companies in the
world
how does one tap into figuring out how
how a customer ticks
you know what it's so much more simple
than anyone
ever gives it credit for it's it's
simple i mean when i
you know when my market research which i
hate those terms because it's so
corporate to me is start with my friends
if my friends like something i'm like
that's a good start my sister my kids
and then you could you know then you've
got your entire social
uh you know a stratosphere to ask
questions i knew i had a hit with jones
road when i started just listening to
the you know customers and telling me
exactly what they think and feel so you
know i'm like you i talk back to people
it's just it's in my nature but so much
of who we are and what we do is right in
the palm of your hands and so many
brilliant
founders and ceos they think there's
something out there that they could
you know learn or get from someone else
and by the way the answer is in the room
always
with jones like what was your hypothesis
and then what adjusted as you listened
along the way
you know it's exactly what i had in my
mind it's what i probably would have
done you know if i had the power and
ability to change things when i was you
know part of a big company that was
impossible
so and it was just everything was just
really timely so when i launched you
know i'd look i couldn't talk to anyone
about it before i launched because i had
non-compete so the day i launched it was
like you know taking a chance people
will hate this because so much of makeup
in the industry is heavy and contoured
and thick and very popular and this is
the opposite of that but i really
believed in it and i believe there was
enough people that want this i don't
expect to get everyone but i
you know if anything i think that i've
been blown away by how many people
actually want to wear makeup and just
let me feel better
and it's really again you know i'm a
chicago girl everything is simple to me
yeah
talk about that simplicity the chicago
girl do you do you think that
people put too much academics around
consumer behavior
i 100
and you know the the the good news about
me is i get overwhelmed reading
brilliant things that people say i just
it like clogs my brain so then i just
start all over and think about what i
what i really think and then you know
figure out what to act on don't get me
wrong i i surround myself you know with
brilliant people that know things that i
don't like my gm you know we happen to
have a great relationship she could
explain to me i she's 31 i could explain
to her and it were and it works but you
know so much of our story is the same
because we're not your classic you know
educated
anything i know you know my business
degree i i got from life as did you and
i had a store in my basement growing up
with my friends a jewelry store it was
gorgeous and wonderful but you know what
there was no foot traffic so it didn't
really succeed
i love that um you weren't you weren't
able to convince some of the uh
neighbors to come through no i don't
think my parents let me but we did have
we're not we're not letting strangers
into our basement bobby um
given the fact that you built from the
streets then you have this incredible
opportunity to sell your business which
is a monumental thing for many
entrepreneurs then you're in a corporate
environment which for street kids like
you and i is like
you know like i work i have an agency
that works with corporate companies and
it's hard for me but i still control my
business i
my compassion
towards what you had to go through
during that time but it's difficult
right you know for us our companies are
our babies
now you're watching it in this
conglomerate and back to your point
we learned by doing a lot of people in
business learn you know get into
positions by reading about it
like what was the you know because i
know there's a lot of people watching
right now who are considering to sell
their company
you know there's obviously the financial
gain that comes along with that but
there's an emotional aspect towards that
that i don't think a lot of people talk
about
instead of going because i want to stay
on theme
i'm going to go into a very narrow place
of this what surprised you without
naming names or going you know but what
surprised you about the out of touchness
of big corporations with the with the
consumer and and what did you learn and
what are some of the themes there and
things for people look out for if they
sell their company and have to navigate
that business within a big company right
sorry there's a lot of answers with that
so i'm going to be really great first of
all the thing is you got four minutes so
yeah
i got i need 30 seconds so what the main
thing that i learned working with a lot
of people at the table in really
beautiful suits from all over the world
but honestly it was a very good looking
you know
crowd but what i learned was
everybody has an idea everyone knows
better and because i'm you know i'm
not one of them i'd listen to them and i
could
fight and i'm not i wasn't going to
fight what i learned is to listen to sit
back
when it was time give my opinion
and say to them and this also is why i'm
happily married 33 years that i hear
what you're saying that's an interesting
idea because that's honestly you know
you have to figure out how you get along
with people to make the best decisions
for your company and now that i have you
know 12 people that work for me and my
only investor is my business partner my
husband
so
um you know i it's the same thing i hear
what you're saying and i want him to say
it to me i hear what you're saying
that's kind of the most important thing
and i do advise a lot of founders they
call me up and they ask me and i give
them the good bad and the ugly and you
know i stayed 22 years after i sold the
company i don't know
no it's incredible
insane and gary who would think that at
60 i left the company i was 59 years old
i'm 64 now
you know i founded a new makeup company
who in a million years would have
thought that you know there is life
after
one big thing you do yeah
yeah you noticed i'm obsessed with this
i'm like what's the matter with people
yeah you're you're you are more on fire
and vibrant right now than 87 of the 29
year olds i know on earth like i don't
understand why people listen we've as a
society have started to go after certain
issues around the world like around
gender and race and thing and religion
we need to start talking about ageism
like this concept that like we have 36
year olds bobby who are watching this
right now who think their life is over
and they [ __ ] it up they didn't do
they're like people are confused as [ __ ]
with age bobby yeah but this really
great thing that's happening um right
now there's so many bad things in the
world happening but the really great
thing is everyone has permission to do
something else to stop whatever isn't
working for you don't do it and do
something else and just i don't care
what it is you'll figure out how to make
money but but just follow your dream and
take chances and honestly don't forget
about happiness don't forget about your
health and don't forget about your
personal life you know your kids like
all those things actually matter and you
know work is my my joy but you know i'm
one day i'll have grandkids and you know
i think i'll be an even happier person
of course and and it's amazing i mean
like we both live this life it's amazing
to have work be your hobby we spend so
much time on work
work so many people look at work the way
i looked at school i was depressed six
to eighteen
do you know what sunday nights in the
fall winter and spring felt like for me
like like the worst
i hated it and the fact that people from
22 to 68 live in that place
[ __ ] like people like gary you don't
understand i have bills i'm like live in
a shittier house
right live
have a shittier car don't buy four
dollar [ __ ] coffee like fight for
happiness get a roommate yeah figure
figure it out by the way if you were my
kid because my third kid hated school
and wasn't happy so i let him go to
school in colorado you know as a parent
you've got to kind of follow each
individual personality and figure it out
which is the same thing as your
employees everyone has you know things
that they're good at and things they're
not 100 bobby love you
love you
bye amazing
thanks to you both next we welcome
sophie jameson the chief tick-tock
officer at nerf
and what a story she has
her creative content and love for nerf
earned her over 1.8 million followers on
tick tock and ultimately a c-suite
position at nerf
she's just she was just a junior in
college when she landed it and today
sophie's going to be interviewed by our
very own peter chun svp global head of
partnerships and growth at vaynermedia
welcome to you both
hey everybody thanks so much for that
intro andrea
sophie how are you i'm fantastic how are
you well i've gotten so many messages
from people
just
asking me so many questions to ask you
uh and this is just such a gift for us
to have you on today so thank you but we
have
so let's let's get right into it i think
i think one of the first things everyone
wants to know chief tick-tock officer
first of its kind
give us the origin story how did it
happen what was going on i mean just
looking at your backdrop
it's a pretty natural thread that i
think most people can pull but give us
the reveal tell us about that
yeah i'll make it quick for you guys so
i was posting on tick tock right around
last year right when covet hit uh we
were in quarantine didn't have much else
to do got around 1.5 million followers
and then nerf created this job where the
application was via tiktok which was
really cool in its own regard uh so i
made a tick tock applied and i had a
formal interview and then they said
we'll call you back in a bit and then
they call me back 12 hours later and i
got the job
you know i i remember when we first
spoke and you told me the two weeks
we'll get back to you in two weeks and
it was actually 12 hours
um that that to me is just such major
props to the hasbro nerf organization
and just understanding what their
strengths are and what they need to
figure out and being able to put you in
a place to move so quickly
so it's a huge congrats so tell us about
the role like what's the job the
day-to-day do you truly have autonomy um
you know we talk a lot about having this
freedom in a framework because of all
the things tick-tock requires which is
speed speed speed and kind of moving at
the speed of culture but tell us about
the day-to-day and almost a little bit
around you know your role and how the
infrastructure of the organization
supports you because i think a lot a lot
of companies are are looking to figure
that out now
yeah so it is a very independent job um
you know i don't really have anybody
checking in you know on a day-to-day
basis i create around five tick tocks a
week and then we go through a whole
process of making sure that they're okay
and then posting them in the following
weeks but if there's a trend which is
super important a trend that's trending
on tick tock we'll hop on it and usually
produce a piece of content within 12
hours of seeing the trend
uh so just expediting those approval
processes typically i just sent it to my
boss and even if he doesn't get it i go
no it's gonna work trust me and then uh
the the best part about just the nerf
team in general is that they're so
welcoming to mistakes which i just think
is so crucial in in this landscape you
know we'll post a tick tock and i'll say
i'm so sorry that didn't do well and
they'll say what are you talking about
we learned so much from that we'll never
do that type of video again and that's
invaluable which is a really cool
perspective
wow wow so how often do you think
things don't work out on the platform
that there's an inside gain that helps
empower the next version
yeah i'd say even you know like
75 of the time or something insane like
that you know if you're posting every
day one hits a week that's that's
typical and then all the other ones you
learn and improve
that's that's that's such an important
point and i feel like even folks at
vayner we are very contemporary creative
media strategy organization and we love
hacking platforms and moving quickly but
even within our own organization there
is a sense that you can go viral
overnight on the platform and and coming
from you it's just great to hear 75
failed and so the notion isn't to start
to think about oh my gosh this isn't
working you just have to continue to
post more and more get in the comments
learn grab the insight and reproduce
which is incredible which is which gets
us kind of to the next question here
which
almost every person was messaging me
about which is what makes a good tick
tock
yep and i wish i had a secret formula
and i could just say a and b bam you're
viral
it's not that easy the first thing i
always say is and this is applies to
everything in life enjoy what you're
making if you make a video and you don't
like it you can immediately tell and
people are going to be turned off and
not want to watch it i'm passionate
about every single tech talk that i
create whether or not it does well
that's that's honestly the most
important thing and that comes in
together with authenticity and just
being yourself on camera creating tick
tocks that you actually like and then
just continually learning you know from
past mistakes like i said you kind of
start to create your own formula and
it's going to be different for every
single influencer every single brand uh
there's no one size fits all which i
actually love um but it's also a
headache for a lot of marketers but
there's no one-size-fits-all on
tick-tock
so look two things you already dropped
two gems on everybody here one which is
75 of the tick tocks crate won't work
and two it's almost like every tick tock
requires something new and you
constantly have to be creating it into
being there
are there any kind of recent learnings
you've had from the posts you've put up
sophie that just seemed to be
kind of not to say you need to game the
algorithm but the algorithm obviously is
a huge component here uh brands trying
to trying to hack the for you pages is
always top of mind unless the tips to
hack but kind of what seems to be
working today
yeah definitely just doing the trends
and and seeing what the viewers like
what gets really great engagements and
you can learn a lot from your comments
you can
you know they're not always positive but
there's a lot that you can learn from
them and if you take it with the right
attitude and perspective every single
comment can give you some piece of
insight
but we also have just been doing this
format where we try to be as like real
as possible and and just be like
this is what it's like as chief tick
tock officer kind of pull the curtain
back and those tend to do pretty well as
well
yeah you know you just mentioned
something there about being real number
one and number two that not all comments
are positive
and a lot of our brands i think struggle
with the speed of reacting in comments
and posts and like we like to call it
splintering different tick tocks off of
what seems to be working
because it's just kind of like the
structure that they have internally
but also just
their concern and i want to say
insecurity but just the you know you
don't want to have to deal with a
pr comment or a bad brand comment but
what do brands need to have in place to
be able
to move quick like what have you put in
place if you think nerf allows and if
it's kind of we discuss freedom in a
firmware but
is it just truly
you
please just have to test and learn but
what do some brands and organization
you're breaking up so bad unfortunately
right now
on my end oh yeah
just
hear me out
uh it's not terrific but i can answer
what i heard of the question
um so as far as that goes we all have a
lot of autonomy thank you friend and we
all have access to the tick tock account
and then we just have you know pretty
basic common sense and then like legal
rules of what to respond but you know at
any time there's like four or five
people that are you know
casually going through the comments when
they have a chance or replying to other
uh brands content as well which is also
a super important thing is to comment on
other brands tick tocks and just do
something fun and we we we comment on a
lot of those and those tend to do well
and we grow from them as well
okay sophie can you hear me
a little bit
bit of
technology challenges but i think we're
going to keep it going
um
incredibly helpful
um but two last quick questions
um or maybe just one last question
uh any brands that stand out
come on in here peter
we're just gonna do a quick he's right
next to me even though it doesn't look
like it we're um i think for whatever
reason your internet's not working mine
is come on in here peter that's so
funny
all right let's keep it going we only
have a couple minutes um just two
i guess one one last question
uh well first and foremost thank you
sophie this has been incredibly
insightful rapid-fire learnings i just
think so many brands had really good
takeaways on what they need to be doing
differently but who are some of the
brands you admire on the platform that
you think are doing a good job today
yeah so
when you first asked me this question
last week i had some like really big
brands come to mind but there's a couple
you know really smaller brands that i
think are just doing phenomenal and
ninety percent of their marketing budget
is tick tock one of them is jersey bird
official they literally are just like a
custom hockey jersey company but their
tick tocks are fire uh they always do
super well they're pretty hilarious they
come across my for you page you know
like often and you know it's made me
want to make a custom jersey and then
another creator is utopia us and he he
creates custom clothing for a bunch of
different brands and the format of his
videos is also just phenomenal
it grabs your attention immediately on
the for you page and both of them i
think all of their marketing is via tick
tock which is super cool
yeah i think i think we're all waiting
for that next wave of disruptors which
is really going to be seated and built
into talk first
understanding how to connect with that
audience
sophie thank you so much for all of the
information and education you've
provided today and just a huge thanks to
nerf as an organization in hasbro for
just being so forward-looking and
creating a role like you to just help
educate the market and brands so thank
you
thank you
thanks sophie and best of luck
what an amazing opportunity
all right up next we welcome roger
soleil
cmo of wework
roger is my hero not only because he was
born in barcelona spain but also because
he has over 20 years of leadership
experience in marketing but also in
innovation of products and services when
roger was cmo at sprint he was named one
of the world's most innovative cmos by
business insider in both 2016 and 2017
and he's all about the chiefs and the
royals
today roger will be joined by vayner
media's svp of media antonia swann
welcome to you both
thanks so much
thank you so much so andrea kind of
stole a little bit of my question roger
but first off thank you so much for
joining it i'm super excited to have
this conversation with you i think as
andrea mentioned about your amazing
background and how impressive it is i
think the audience everyone really wants
to know before we get into consumer's
tick
you were the ceo of sprint
during the t-mobile merger which i'm
sure was an extremely challenging
project
and then you chose to join wework as cmo
about a year and a half ago amid the
whole coven 19 crisis
what were you thinking when you took
that role and we're going into it like
where are we
yeah i like exciting projects i guess
right so
look when i when i joined spring it was
also about doing a turnaround
which we did from
2015 to 2020 and and then once we merged
with t-mobile then my assignment was
over and say okay what's next right and
look we work um
it's a brand that i've always admired uh
it's they have built a very powerful and
interesting product
now you're right in in april 2020 when i
joined it was after the
right after the the failed ipo and uh
there was all this noise about wework uh
but i think that's exactly what it was a
lot of noise that uh and ultimately what
i looked at is what's going to be the
the future starting now right so we have
this
new management team new ceo
wanting to do things very differently uh
then i look at the the actual unit
economics of the business they are
strong
and
and ultimately what matters most is the
product was extremely loved by customers
and and is our nps is very high we have
very loyal members and the product was a
true a truly noticeable product in a
category that had not been disrupted for
many years so ultimately look it's all
about uh challenges this life and and i
love the idea of uh like
finding helping find a way
uh to for wework to to grow
and i saw also ultimately the pandemic
was obviously also a big problem but
also a big a big opportunity right as
all problems are right so
ultimately the the
the idea was what what's going to be the
post-pandemic world right the pandemic
is not going to last forever now even if
it's lasting a little bit longer than we
all expected but uh the point is what's
going to be the the world of office
space and and workspace needs and
collaboration and and teamwork in a
post-pandemic world right and and we all
know it was going to be different
and i think that wework is the the best
company uh to be able to find a way
right and and to find a new way that's
why
after i joined we created this new
positioning that we called uh that's how
tomorrow works
which basically what it uh it shows is
hey we are the future of work um we are
um the the the new ways of working are
gonna be created uh with companies like
wework and then we supported this with
the different evidences like first
health and safety being a priority of
course but then
our product itself being a flexible
product a flexible office space this is
which is something that we're leaning in
even more and more right now our
position is pivoting to smart
flexibility which is ultimately nothing
more than in this
uncertain times in giving um
giving employees and
and companies the ability to to develop
their own hybrid
models of work
and and for that they need an a provider
that actually gives them
flexibility in how they
in in office space so
a space that it's it has no capex that
they can
go and use it and scale their teams up
up and down whenever they want to so
ultimately giving this total flexibility
and giving them the ability to to have
their teams be more productive than ever
without any long-term commitment and
with inspiring spaces that they can find
whenever they want right so
that's that was the idea to rebuild and
to pivot the positioning more from a
co-working space to an actual flexible
space provider so that was the
opportunity i saw amazing thank you so
much you jumped into
many things that i want to talk about
really quickly so the pandemic is
obviously a super big part of this but
two things you came in to wework and you
were super innovative and you guys
created
new programs new products you pivoted as
the consumer was changing their habits
so two questions in this
consumers for you are also two different
things you have b to b
and b to c which is very unique and
people have very different opinions
whether they want to work from home
whether they want to go in once a day or
if you're someone like me you want to
work from new york one week you want to
work from la another week
how are you guys thinking about that and
how consumer trends are changing and and
how you guys were able to really pivot
to that i know you only have three
minutes so i'll let you jump okay no
look great question i think the
consumers they are so companies they are
looking for a way to get their employees
back together in a safe environment and
more importantly in a creative
environment where they can collaborate
and create magic and also build culture
for their companies so that's an
important thing to do and that's where
that's the need that we're trying to
solve for right and we know that
the future is not going to be like the
past right even after the pandemic so
it's accelerated trends that already
happen so no one is looking for spaces
and topicals for people to be nine to
five answering emails it's about
creating intentional spaces where people
can collaborate so that's the actual
need of companies
and then as employee the employees or
the even professionals
or consumers they're looking for places
uh where they can be simply more
productive individually they want to
escape this work from home which many
times it can be difficult and they want
we we count it as work from near home
right places but where you don't need to
commute you can eventually walk there
and find a great space to work and to
find other people and maybe with other
people from your company or even from
all other companies that ultimately
create this great work environment so
this is
one of the needs that that that we've
seen
and in terms of the products that we've
been pivoting them exactly to adjust or
to adapt to these needs right so in
terms of the
this consumer or also from the
enterprise
site we created this product that we
call access which basically it's a
monthly membership that gives you the
ability to go work on any wework
around the world or around the corner
and mostly what's happening is obviously
around the corner uh so you can really
escape from this work from home or you
can have small teams gather into a place
to collaborate
that does not need to be the corporate
headquarters which eventually requires a
huge commute
or or it's simply closed right so then
basically there you can you can have
this flexible space available um we even
have created a version of that that we
call on demand on demand access which is
basically an app where you can book
space by the hour or by the day uh and
we've seen amazing growth on that and
it's the ultimate flexibility of of
office space so that's been
connected to that need of consumers and
then from the enterprise side with uh
leaning to creating this concept of
innovation hubs or collaboration hubs
which ultimately it's a space that is
designed for collaboration and where you
are not really buying or losing 10
spaces for 10 people you're losing the
space maybe for 100 people and then they
rotate and collaborate and they go
whenever they need to and they uh
then and they've they found this purpose
this purpose
together in that space right so that's
the other products that we've been
developing adapted to these new trends
love it so super interesting so you guys
have clearly just gone after flexibility
almost like a class pass but of the
future um one last question i know it's
12.50 i know you love soccer what's your
favorite team what's your favorite team
uh it's uh barza uh football club
barcelona i was born in barcelona and
look this is my team even though
as you mentioned before i've been now
i've been following the case casey uh
chiefs a lot these last five years as i
was in kansas city but uh
big change from soccer to
football
great
thank you
i believe uh
oh
i think we might have a few more minutes
since no one else is jumping on
so i would love to know as oh hey one
more question i was about to jump in
okay
we've got so many more questions roger
and i think we have all the answers
behind you is that right on that board
yes whatever what do you want to know
all the secrets that's right
amazing
thanks to you both
thanks so much
okay take care
last but definitely not least we welcome
lynn schlesinger she is the chief
customer experience officer at forbes
and lynn stepped into this new role just
last month where she is responsible for
delivering digital transformation and
growth by connecting with customers
across forbes today lynn is going to be
joined by nick maridis evp at
vaynermedia and i'm gonna bring him on
watch this
five four three major
it's like magic hello hello hello hi lin
i love that hello nick how are you today
very good thank you for joining us
uh happy to be here
there could not be a more perfect title
for this episode of this show chief
customer experience officer it's a
newish title i've been seeing in the
world you know some announcements
recently i think it's a newish role for
you but maybe we start there where you
know what is this new role all about you
know what are you fired up about in this
new role
well i am so excited about it it is very
new just about six weeks since we made
the announcement and what we're really
trying to do at forbes is position
ourselves for what's next forbes has
been in business for over a hundred
years we've got huge plans to grow and
scale and create new products and
services to support all of our audiences
and i'm going to be looking at through
that through the lens of data technology
and marketing and how do we create this
incredible customer experience wherever
someone is interacting with us no matter
which product or which solution they are
connecting with us on
so the true end to end looking at it the
full 360 of the experience um it's
pretty cool and um sticking true to the
title of this episode in that new role
um how do you in the forbes team think
about figuring out what makes customers
tick i mean that has to be an everyday
always-on thing in the world of
publishing
different from my life and advertising
we have a little bit more time but um
how do you think about it
so we think about it really broadly we
have so many different customers at
forbes and we really try and consider
each of their different needs we have
readers of forbes.com
we have
folks who engage with us through the
social channels we have prince
subscribers who are reading our
beautiful publication every two months
when it hits their mailboxes we have
event attendees and event speakers those
are other audiences we consider and care
for and then we have our incredible
marketing partners another group of
customers that are super important to us
and who we want to
elevate the forbes brand so that they
can elevate their messages through our
different channels
goodness how how big is listening you
know when it comes to how customers tick
you know
across when you got that many different
customers too
it's such a big part of what we do and
something we are now getting uber
focused on and really trying to
understand
what our audiences need and what do they
need from us at different points of
their journey forbes is incredible
because we we we are the media business
media brand for folks who are starting
their entrepreneurial journeys whether
they're young adults or even high school
students who
are entrepreneurial have an
entrepreneurial mindset and want to be
on the 30 under 30 list someday
we have mid-career professionals
we just launched our 50 over 50
franchise focusing on women who are
doing incredible things at the middle of
their careers and then we have an
incredible um
loyal audience of folks who are working
with us through retirement and financial
planning as they look to enjoy the
fruits of all their labors through their
entire career so we really have this
incredible arc an incredible long-term
relationship with our readers in
particular
and we do listen we listen to
what they say certainly when they
provide us direct feedback we see the
kind of content that they're interested
in reading and we want to create more of
that content so that they can always
stay well informed
and we have a slew of new products on
deck
that we will be launching hopefully soon
that we know based on market research
and things we understand from where
people's um
desires are from receiving content that
we're going to be bringing to market um
later this year and next year cool it
sounds like you know in the publishing
world you definitely don't think about
this as an eyeball game you think about
it as a community building game is that
sound right
absolutely we became super focused on
communities um about a year and a half
ago and we really look at developing
these long-term relationships um
with our
all of our different customer sets a
million when forbes um started you know
we really were focused on
recognizing the doers and the doings
both in our pages and in the articles
that we write but also in how we create
um you see that a lot with our
incredible live events both virtual and
in real life these days
and forbes really started with the ethos
of you know business was intended to
bring joy and happiness and we want to
help continue that and the community
part is really important and we look at
not only
um
executive level communities c-suite
communities but we're also really
engaged and really um in touch with the
forbes women community with our forbes
the culture community our different
entrepreneurial communities um are
paramount we want to help all of these
folks who want to learn and engage help
them be successful on their journeys and
it sounds like you have to operate both
in the digital world and hopefully as
you know hopefully kobe passes
eventually back in the live world as
well
absolutely and we think a lot about our
pre-print publication too we have six
beautiful issues a year the tactile
experience of receiving it in the
mailbox and sitting down with a cup of
coffee or a cocktail at the end of the
day and enjoying that experience um is
really part of what we think about as
well
yeah when it comes to the customer
relationship you know what makes people
tick how big is trust in your world you
know as a as a consumer of media you
know these days it's like i don't know
what to think half the time when i'm
looking at a headline you know is that
is that a factor in how you think about
you know customer relationship
absolutely because without trust really
what do you have right we want um we
want to continue
to be a loyal partner with all of our
with all of our customers and all of our
audiences
and there's trust not only in the
journalism the content that we bring to
life but there's also trust in how we
handle customer data right are we doing
with it what they've given us permission
to do
are we um do we have the okay to send
marketing materials do we have the okay
to invite people to participate in
community activities or different forums
and we take that really seriously
it's the thing i've been thinking a lot
about is what marketing activity are we
all doing as marketers that are actually
like
you know having the consumer push back
on us you know with whether it's how we
use data whether it's the constant
spamming through email like is that
something you all think about of like
you know how much is too much you know
um how in the living room can you be
with people
we we do we try not to be intrusive we
tried to take the cues and the
information that we have to send people
relevant information sell them send them
regular relevant content
so that their time spent with forbes
whether it's through the print pages or
the digital pages or an event is
valuable time spent and they can walk
away thinking they got from it what they
hope to
um we got one minute left um let's let's
shift gears a little bit so as you as a
as a customer right who i'm sure has
lots of brands in your life
what brand are you insanely
loyal to
how how good are they are they at
understanding how to make you tick you
know what do you look for in the brands
that you love
oh that's a that is such a hard question
about how i answer that but i am
look i'm i'm a really big fan of peloton
and was before the pandemic i i luckily
um got my bike
almost almost nine months before um
things started to shut down and i have
really found great joy in the brand and
the content they deliver and the
experiences they allow for
one of the things i really love is that
i can
work out myself and do my own thing in
my own in my own basement or i can join
a group class and really be part of all
of the energy and excitement that can
come with that so i think they've done
that really well and they've definitely
had some hiccups along the way but i
think they've handled them with grace
and transparency and um i i can't wait
to see what else they come out with
amazing i think i'm gonna go in after
that audrey's back
thank you nick that was amazing awesome
speed together
we are double backs
um
i'm gonna close it out all right then
thank you so much um thank you both i'll
see you soon
i'll step out do you think and
congratulations lin on your new role how
exciting
love this new title that's coming out
all right well we just want to thank
everybody for joining today's marketing
for the now and please join us on
september 16th 12 to 1 pm
eastern time you'll be hearing all about
what it takes to be a successful
entrepreneur from founders and ceos
including
alexis ohanian from reddit mindy
grossman ceo of ww um otherwise known as
weight watchers
lauren malian the ceo of digital
undivided and shelly haas the cmo of
ulta beauty and until then hashtag
marketing for the now check us out on
our past recordings and we'd love to
hear from you thanks everybody for
joining today